customers customers customer customer
custom customers customer customers
hello believe nation today I'm going to
show you 10 ways to amaze your customers
treat people at the end of the
relationship like it's the beginning and
it won't be an end and that's not just
your intimate relationship what if your
customers what if you fell in love with
your customers with your clients more
than your product more than your company
if your entire life was about meeting
their needs if you would do what for
your customers client you would do what
if you love your customers and clients
you'd do anything guess what they're
gonna love you but most people love
their customers and clients as long as
they buy from them do what they want
respond to them and then they don't they
go that's the end you want clients for
life not just customers fall in love of
them it's a different focus isn't it
it's a different meaning and that
creates a different life because you
make decisions differently from that
place it's necessary that you'll be
flexible that you are always thinking of
how can I improve this better this is a
customer driven economy it's necessary
for you to always explore various ways
in which you can improve the quality of
service that you're providing for the
people in your organization I remember
something a major company had talked
about the extra value service they were
providing for their customers and the
lady who had the news conference
summarized it this way she said it's not
our intention to satisfy our customers
or to please our customers our intention
is to amaze them it's necessary if
you're going to compete today that you
look for ways to amaze your customers by
being one of those individuals that keep
your commitments they keep your word
that's relentless it's necessary as you
work with the people that you bring into
all your organization that they see that
you are a good example of a person to
work with because you model integrity
and determination and ambition and truth
and honesty and the way in which you
conduct business in nineteen in 2001
it snowed in New Jersey on December 23rd
which was one of the busiest days of the
year
typically December 23rd is the busiest
day of the year in a liquor store and a
woman called us we just started shipping
and her case of behringer White
Zinfandel wasn't delivered first of all
I appreciate the people that know what
behringer white sin is good job the
entire case by the way 15 pack the
entire 15 pack case cost $45 we're doing
about $40,000 an hour in the store she
calls I find out about it somehow it was
buzzing I was on the floor selling I am
the premiere salesman on the floor as
you can imagine I find out about it and
we're debating what to do she needs it
for her Christmas dinner I grabbed the
case throw it in my car and drive to
Bergen County to deliver it it takes me
two and a half hours to complete the
whole thing the woman was a hundred and
ninety four years old
we didn't have a lot of lifetime value
on the back end there she looked like
Yoda and the best part was I delivered
it all pumped with myself and she said
great and close the door awesome
everybody especially my dad who was
pissed that I left because all the
customers that came in asking for me or
that I could have sold everybody who's
baffled I can't tell you what the ROI of
driving through the snow in my car to
deliver a case of $45 pink to a woman
that looked like Yoda was but I can tell
you this over the next two to three
years that story became the foundation
of how we treated every single customer
it became our competitive edge and those
are the things that matter to me I love
black and white data I'm obsessed with
it the day when the nerd beat me I
understood that the nerds beat me and I
respect the living out of data
conversion funnels all that but I'm
telling you right now that there are way
too many running businesses today with
this and not enough people running
businesses with this
and again I swear on my life I am not
Mother Teresa and I far from run my
business just on this but I'm telling
you right now the reason I amassed my
following the reason why I continued to
retain it is because my percentage of
this far outweighs everything in this
room I mean it that's how I feel and
that's how I try to roll every day and I
promise you if you are able to figure
out how to afford how to afford the
allocation of this in your business more
your long term value will be
dramatically higher your long term
business success will be dramatically
higher your grandparents your
great-grandparents build businesses
based on this it's how we built the
whole thing we got really lean and mean
when we went to the suburbs and big box
stores and all we cared about was
dollars and it's great and the data
matters and continue to use it and use
this tool and understand it but I'm
asking you one final thing when you go
home if this talk meant anything and by
the way I fundamentally believe only
three of you were gonna act on this talk
I do because what I talk about is
ridiculously hard and massively
frustrating and takes forever you know
like everything that's good in life if
you do anything because of this keynote
there's only one thing I ask you to do
because as any as I got I'm a practical
here's what I want from you when you go
home look yourself in the mirror and
audit everything you and your business
do I promise you that if you audit from
top to bottom of expenses and effort and
time and energy and payroll and all that
if you audit all of it even the best of
us even the InBev's which is the company
that bought Budweiser they built their
whole business on like printing on both
sides of the paper and all that horse
even the most efficient ones of us are
doing 20% dumb if you take that 8% that
13%
that's 16 percent of dumbshit that
you're doing paying that person that's
not bringing any cultural value to your
business having that contract that
you've just been in you just renew
because your busiest whatever you're
doing if you take any piece of that
percentage and you apply it to giving a
about your customer it will be better
for your business going forward because
for the first time since we all lived in
small
towns where your reputation was the
complete backbone of how you did
business for the first time because
technology is bringing us back together
in a small town for the first time being
good and caring and following up matters
it matters how about doing something
random act of kindness for a current
customer not the ones that unsubscribed
or left you know how you always do nice
when they're going how about while
you've got them reallocate your thought
process I'm telling you because the
tools that the is the umbrella of this
organism en't are getting so good so
good you know what that means
all that she's about to become a
commodity emotional e.q is going to
dominate business over the next decade
and I implore you start paying attention
and oh by the way I'll leave you with
this you know what the best part is it
feels good thank you
see the most important thing in business
is you have to know your customer and
then you have to speak to that customer
and then don't try to be everything to
everybody they we do one thing urban
America that's all I do and that's very
very important and so we have the number
one TGI Fridays in the West restaurant
red in Los Angeles only Fridays they
serve Cristal Don Perry owned XO because
that's what my what because summer wants
god I know your customer and we believe
they cook on very different from the
Wall Street we believe custom number one
in point number two share another
customer one employee yeah are we again
this is my religion you know if you it's
the custom that pass the money it's the
employees that drive the innovation it's
the shareholder in the shareholder
always say you know I've got remember
the day before we IPO and a lot of
people say can I keep out the shares we
were long-term shareholders but when the
crisis came these guys long assumed it
you know there
ran away why the people stayed custom
stayed I used to work for Warren Davis
the guy who started Avis rent-a-car and
he said to me one day
Robert what's the purpose of business
and I said oh make a profit and all
these other things they said no the
purpose of business is to create a
customer because everything else takes
care of itself if you can create
customers and create value for them
because the answer that question is
different for every single customer then
you're gonna have a great business yeah
I mean I would like to grow with our
customer you know I I think you know
protecting the brand is really important
because what's made us successful I want
to honor at every opportunity in the
future and I think it's what's going to
make a successful in the future how we
do that will be different it won't be is
like half hazard or cute or you know
whatever as it has been in the past but
I think like what's worked about
building the business to this date you
know in some way we have to find a way
to extend into you know growing the
business in the future and it's
important that we don't that we don't
alienate our customer you know and
that's a difficult thing you know in
America as a corporation you know to to
continue to stay friends with our
customer which we always have been it's
a very high priority of mine but it's
really hard to control all the moving
pieces of a business with you know close
to 300 employees and buying you know
found sense if you know ten I don't even
know if it's tens of thousands or
whatever excuse you know throughout the
year making sure that's all right and
every person who answers the phone is
you know doing a good job and no
customer feels like they're wrapped up
in some really big machine you know and
and on some level a big company you know
that's that's what that's what it is but
I think there are ways of humanizing
that at every opportunity and that
something that I'm interested in well I
think that I can relate to every woman
out there I have been every size there
is so I know how to dress every every
body type I truly believe that you know
it's not just about high-fashion
we all need pieces in our wardrobe that
are fashionable but accessible wearable
you know and affordable I think that
that's really what has made the brand
such a success I start new ideas every
single week and I think what drives me
used to don't get me wrong
money used to drive me but then when you
pass by some of these you know goals
that you're chief you don't another
level is weird to explain it and it's
hard to explain it but I think it's a
fear of failure that keeps me going and
always wanting to make a difference for
my customers always wanting to give them
the best fit the best quality and you
have just started up Ultima Beauty
altima you turn what turn a new tanning
product you Street on of smell of
biscuits etc it's launched in Boots
Debenhams rusev these are high V Nichols
had its launch all over and I just love
the challenge and you know I try and
keep it real I'll do my best to keep it
real because you know what was another
beggar brought to mercy much bigger than
than me
and I still still believe that I have
not made it yet
I don't believe up Medicare I'm going to
teaching the common-sense rules to
ensure front-of-house runs smoothly
starting with the basics on the menu
tonight I think everything should should
you'll be quite sending out if you're
into fish your meat is your favorite but
everything tonight is absolutely fresh
stop yeah yeah okay right what you need
to do is relax a great service is
attentive without being noticed
so far you're making my pitch and hasn't
come out yet that's how we were tasting
you are right ladies sit down with Don
and I at the table take an order of four
okay right off we go here we go
good evening everyone and for you orders
tonight what would you like the beetroot
starter and the halibut for Maine please
the beetroot by Canadian up you know yes
it was painful here's the thing sit down
yeah where's the patty look at that
I swear to God is writing of a six year
old it's all about engaging in the
customers to start off with don't always
like to start Manimal prawns ever
Michael's certainly so P and C and Madam
mackerel halibut so they of course
lovely and it's just the P MMC see that
is it goddamn revelations relax you
don't have to have everything in detail
here yeah that'll be surprised three
tables land the line thirty tables down
the line if you continue to work at it
you start to become incredibly charming
Joe why because your confidence levels
up there thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know which of the ten clips had the
biggest impact on you and why leave it
in the comments below and I will join in
the discussion thank you again
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon